ce jour là les enfants de l'ardèche vont
à la rencontre de l'histoire de leur
département
deux classes de l'école primaire de
privat sur les traces de leurs
prédécesseurs
une histoire vivante sur le terrain le
passé revit grâce à la rencontre de deux
générations
alors pourquoi des grosses ici il faut
remonter très loin dans le temps très
très loin parce que c'est une histoire
qui commence
il y a environ 200 millions d'années
c'est très loin
et alors il y à 200 millions d'années en
ardèche qu'est ce qu'il y avait est ce
que quelqu'un le sait pas encore c'est
dans ces grottes que se réfugier la
communauté protestante au moment des
dragonnades des cavernes aménagé
dissimulé au creux de la végétation
aujourd'hui plus de deux siècles se sont
écoulés l'histoire est enfoui au fond
des mémoires et les vestiges ont été
pillés c'est un jeune turc employés à la
maison des associations qui se charge de
faire ressurgir le passé pour arriver à
trouver tous les documents là j'ai dû
faire des recherches sur les aux
archives départementales de de l'ardèche
a pris 20 et dans des documents de la
société d'histoire et d'archéologie de
privas et à vraiment suffisamment de
documents pour tout apprendre pas tout
non non c'est sûr qu'elle est à
documents qui sont peut-être pas encore
consulté mais il ya il ya déjà avec tout
ce qu'on a déjà vont tout ce que j'ai pu
dire lorna visite bon ben on en est
quand même à peu près sûr où les
hypothèses sont vraiment deux hypothèses
quand même relativement confirmée en
fait la visite commence et de genre
plutôt se termine
elle est le symbole de ce que veut être
la maison des associations un trait
d'union entre générations
ce jour là les enfants de l'ardèche vont
à la rencontre de l'histoire de leur
département
deux classes de l'école primaire de prix
va suivre les traces de leurs
prédécesseurs
une histoire vivante sur le terrain le
passé revit grâce à la rencontre de deux
générations
alors pourquoi des grosses ici or il
faut remonter très loin dans le temps
très très loin parce que c'est une
histoire qu'ils commencent
il y a environ 200 millions d'années
c'est très loin
et alors il y à 200 millions d'années en
ardèche qu'est ce qu'il y avait est ce
que quelqu'un le sait non pas encore
c'est dans ces grottes que se réfugier
la communauté protestante au moment des
dragonnades des cavernes aménagé
dissimulé au creux de la végétation
aujourd'hui plus de deux siècles se sont
écoulés l'histoire est enfoui au fond
des mémoires et les vestiges ont été
pillés c'est un jeune turc employés à la
maison des associations qui se charge de
faire ressurgir le passé pour arriver à
trouver tous les documents mais j'ai dû
faire des recherches sur les aux
archives départementales de de l'ardèche
à privas et dans des documents de la
société d'histoire et d'archéologie de
privas y'a vraiment suffisamment même
document pour tout apprendre pas tout
non non c'est sûr qu'elle est à
documents qui sont peut-être pas encore
consulté mais il ya il ya déjà avec tout
ce qu'on a déjà vont tout ce que j'ai pu
dire lors de la visite bon ben on en est
quand même à peu près sûr où les
hypothèses sont vraiment deux hypothèses
quand même relativement confirmée en
fait la visite commencée deux heures
plus tôt se termine
elle est le symbole de ce que peut être
la maison des associations un trait
d'union entre générations